herr Weber vielleicht die erste Frage an
Sie 52 Prozent versus 48 Prozent Erdogan
wiedergewählt der See im Hintergrund wie
geht ihre Erklärung dafür bevor wir Frau
drüten fragen die gestern glaube ich
noch in Istanbul war
ist ein Experte ist auch angesichts der
wohnbaubeteiligung und demokratisches
Ergebnis dass die Türkinnen und Türken
gegeben haben das gilt es auch zu
respektieren auch den Wahl gewinnen zu
gratulieren ich glaube das ist viel auch
mit Identität im Land zu tun hat zu
welchem Lager man sich bezieht Religion
hat Rolle gespielt in der Türkei im
Wahlkampf auf die Frage wie geht man im
Westen und mit den USA Schweden NATO
diese Fragen und Rolex spielt und
insofern ist das Land zerrissen das ist
das was wir sehen und dann ist es
offensichtlich gelungen über die Jahre
hinweg seine Wahl Wählerbasis zu
stabilisieren die Leute waren Bord zu
halten die ihn unterstützen und die
Opposition hat trotzdem Geschlossenheit
nicht geschafft
rücken wir haben uns vor ein paar Wochen
schon äh hier genau darüber unterhalten
sie haben über diese Spaltung der
türkischen Gesellschaft gesprochen sie
sagten auch ähnlich wie Herr Weber da
geht's auch um Identitätspolitik das
heißt wie groß ist der Kater bei denen
ist ja fast die Hälfte des Landes die
jetzt nicht den Mann da vorne sehen Sie
eigentlich gerne gehabt hätten ja der
ist groß fünf weitere Jahre Erdogan
damit haben die Unterstützer der
Opposition vielleicht so in der Form
nicht gerechnet es gab ja eine große
große Hoffnung auf Wechsel interessant
finde ich aber auch was bei der Wahl
eben keine Rolle gespielt hat denn sie
haben das gesagt also ja es ging um
Identitätspolitik aber die türkische
Lira ist wahnsinnig schwach wir haben
eine hohe Inflation wir haben
autoritären Regierungsstil wir haben
verheerende Erdbeben gehabt im Februar
und auch Mängel der
Regierungspolitik haben dabei eine Rolle
gespielt und das hat alles nicht
gereicht um den Wechsel herbeizuführen
und ich glaube daran sieht man ganz gut
wie ähm ja wie stark diese beiden Lager
sind also das ist eben nicht reicht die
einen auf die andere Seite zu ziehen es
geht nicht nur um Politik es geht um
Identität es geht um den Kern der
Menschen und das war eben nicht so die
Menschen bereit waren jetzt ihre
Position bei dieser Wahl zu ändern weißt
doch wir haben uns letztes Mal drüber
unterhalten der sagten sie na ja also
was er dann da gerade gemacht hat und
wir haben es ja gerade wirklich in
dafür auch gesehen also geschält
Geschenke Geldgeschenke zu verteilen das
hat er ja auch im ganz großen Stil
gemacht und sie sagten also wer auch
immer da jetzt in den nächsten fünf
Jahren ans Ruder kommt der findet leere
Kassen das ist ein ziemliches Desaster
das heißt im Grunde muss er jetzt
auslöffeln was er sich selber
eingebrockt hat eigentlich schon ja also
auch die Lehrer wurde ja künstlich
stabilisiert die Wirtschaft ist
eigentlich in einem schlechten Zustand
aber Erdogan behaart ja darauf auf
seinen Kurs also er ist ja der festen
Meinung dass ein hoher Leitzins gleich
hohe Inflation bedeutet und ein
niedriger als sonst niedrige Inflation
wo in die meisten
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler vehement
widersprechen würden aber er fährt
diesen Kurs eben weiter denn er sorgt
sich darum wenn er das Geld wieder
teurer macht das dann viele Menschen
auch pleite gehen die Kredite zum
Beispiel aufgenommen haben also er will
eigentlich unbedingt versuchen dass die
Menschen ihre Kaufkraft beibehalten er
hat ja auch die Löhne erhöht den
Mindestlohn erhöht all diese Sachen
gemacht um mit Macht zu versuchen jetzt
vor der Wahl die Wirtschaft nicht
erforschen zu lassen wie das jetzt
weitergeht wird man sehen also eine
einfache Situation ist das jetzt nicht
ich weiß nicht ob sie sich erinnern
letztes Mal hatte ich schon so ein Hauch
von Zweifel geäußert ob wir nicht
manchmal an etwas schräges Bild auf die
Türkei haben die ist nicht gerade ich
habe auch gleich diesbezüglich eine
Frage an Sie
im Sinne von wir schätzen manchmal Dinge
etwas falsch und etwas seltsam ein was
ist denn der eigentliche Grund dafür
dass die Türkinnen die Türken jetzt dann
doch in der Mehrheit und dann doch
eigentlich relativ klar diesen Mann
wieder zum Präsidenten gewählt haben und
das auch schon so oft getan haben für
beide Lager war es eigentlich nur
Schicksalswahl also für die Anhänger der
Opposition die haben gesagt so das ist
jetzt die Lösung hier wieder auf dem
Vater Demokratie zurückzukommen und für
die Anhänger von Erdogan die sagen also
er ist ein Mann aus unserer Mitte er
kommt von uns und er hat unsere Zukunft
gesichert er hat uns ein besseres Leben
ermöglicht und er hat zum Beispiel auch
viel ja getan für die konservative
Bevölkerung Frauen mit Kopftüchern die
durften früher nicht studieren die
durften nicht im Staatsdienst arbeiten
und unter Erdogan wurden diese Gesetze
geändert das heißt die Leute sind ihm
sehr dankbar dafür sie sagen er hat uns
klingt jetzt ein bisschen absurd
eigentlich die Freiheit gebracht diesen
Menschen und für das andere Religion so
zu leben wie wir das gerne möchten und
für das andere Lager muss das absurd
klingen weil natürlich Journalisten im
Gefängnis sitzen Menschenrechtler im
Gefängnis sitzen also das sind zwei
Lager es geht nicht nur um Politik es
geht um viel viel mehr und ich glaube
deshalb war das auch bei dieser Wahl so
dass die Lage relativ stark geblieben
sind auch wenn es der Opposition ja
gelungen ist sehr sehr viele Stimmen
dazu zu gewinnen also die waren ja
stärker als
gesamte Millionen von Türken sind in
dieser Zeit aufgestiegen in einer
relativ wohlhabende Mittelschicht
eigentlich erst geschafft ne also auch
ein anderes
Autobahn gebaut Brücken gebaut Flughäfen
gebaut also unter ihm ist das Land
eigentlich sehr sehr vorangekommen und
das Halten ihm viele seiner Anhänger
auch heute noch zugute also ich war in
einem Ort da hat er nach dem ersten
Wahlgang muss man sagen 88% geholt also
eine wahnsinnige Zahl und da haben uns
auch viele Menschen berichtet so der hat
uns doch ein besseres Leben ermöglicht
so was wollt ihr eigentlich so das war
die Haltung die ich davor gefunden habe
ja
gesagt das Volk hat Erdogan gewählt und
wir haben das zu akzeptieren und haben
uns auch gefälligst nicht einen zu
müssen
demokratische Wahl und
irgendwann hat offensichtlich überzeugt
mit seinen Qualitäten ist sehr
führungsstark hat das Land glaube ich
nach außen hin auch sehr kraftvoll
auftreten lassen eigenständig auftreten
lassen und hat eben im Land auch einiges
geschaffen das ist nicht die Wahl der
der Europäer ist oder unsere Perspektive
das müssen wir akzeptieren ich glaube
schon dass wir auch Einfluss hätten
besseren Einfluss wir müssen die Türkei
glaube ich ernster nehmen ich habe
gesagt wir müssen Sie ein bisschen
umarmen für mich ist die oder die Türkei
wirklichen europäisches Land wenn Sie
eine Weste Türkei unterwegs sind in
Istanbul da dann ist es eine europäische
Metropole und ich glaube schon dass wir
mit unseren Politik einen
Beitritt auszuschließen die Türkei auch
so ein bisschen auszugrenzen auch sehr
starke man kritisieren
nicht dazu beitragen dass sich die
Türkei uns zuwende dem Westen zu werden
die Frage des EU-Beitritts die sie da
gerade ansprechen zum Beispiel sie
werden dafür die Türkei den ich werde
dafür die Türkei näher an Europa wieder
heranzuführen das heißen ist ein großes
Land ist strategisch außerordentlich
wichtig für den besten NATO mitnehmen
darf sie nicht einfach da lassen wo sie
ist und dem Orient übergeben damit würde
man aber auch die Politik Erdogans
belohnen
ich glaube letztlich geht es ums Volk
und Politiker gehen und kommen hat jetzt
vielleicht eine Legislaturperiode
vielleicht auch nur eine halbe es geht
um die Türkei und die muss weit über so
ein politikerleben hinausgehen und
Türkei gehört für mich zu Europa sollte
Bestandteil von Europa sein und kann
viel europäischer werden
sieht Manfred Weber glaube ich
vollkommen anders
ich sehe dass die Türkei extrem
wichtiger Partner ist denke an
Wirtschaftsfragen die übrigens nicht
natürlich auch unsere Europäer und drei
wie kann man Wohlstand sicher in der
Zukunft die Energie Fragen kann die
Türkei wichtiger Partner sein ich denke
an Zypern gespaltenes europäisches Land
über die Türkei dringend brauchen dass
wir da eigentlich dauerhaft Frieden
schaffen und diese Blockade beenden die
Migrationsfrage ist mega Thema unsere
Zeit also sie haben so viele Fragen wo
wir unbedingt miteinander brauchen
deswegen extrem wichtiger Partner ich
bin nur der Meinung dass die die
Jahrzehnte in denen wir jetzt dieser
Vater marganer der Vollmitgliedschaft
nachgelaufen sind uns entfremdet haben
in diesen Zeiten weil in der Türkei das
Gefühl war die wollen uns eigentlich
nicht richtig in der EU die meinen das
gar nicht ernst und in der EU war das
Gefühl da wir über denen unser Projekt
es kann nicht funktionieren mit der
Türkei es wird nicht funktionieren und
für mich da muss man definieren mal was
ist die Europäische Union überhaupt das
Projekt das ist eine Freihandelszone
Geschäft machen dann kann man die Türkei
dazu nehmen dann hätte man auch die Idee
von anderen nachgehen können irgendwann
Russland heute zunehmen bevor wir jetzt
diesen schlimmen Krieg hatten aber wenn
man die Europäische Union als das als
die Verteidigung unseres Lebensmodells
sieht dass wir in der Welt von morgen
Rolle spielen als Identität sieht dann
glaube ich wenn ich heute in Hamburg auf
die Straße gehe oder in München auf die
Straße gehe und den Leuten die Frage
gestellt hat das kurdengebiets Europa
dann werden die Leute sagen ich will der
enge Zusammenarbeit ich will viel
Partnerschaft mit den Kurden aber kurz
vor die irakischen Grenze das ist nicht
mehr Europa und es gibt die Identität es
gibt so Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl und
es müssen Politiker berücksichtigen wenn
Sie diese erweiterungsschritte gehen
deswegen dezidiert enge Partnerschaft
volle Zusammenarbeit und ich hoffe wir
können jetzt auch ein neues Kapitel
öffnen mit Erdogan eben wieder gewählt
aber auf der anderen Seite auch ehrlich
machen sich ehrlich machen weil also
eine EU-Mitgliedschaft der Türkei sagen
sie heute wird es nicht geben definitiv
nicht
aber auf wie lange ich glaube das ist
das auf Dauer nicht geben wird und auch
auf Dauer nicht geben soll die Türkei
ist ähnlich wie andere Staaten unserer
Nachbarschaft wichtiges Bindeglied
Wissens wenn ich mit der
Europäer mit der europäischen
Einstellung von Staaten von Städten wie
sie sagen mit Istanbul oder ankar
argumentiert dann kann ich auch sagen
auch sagen dass Tel Aviv für sehr
europäische Stadt ist Israel auf Israel
Mitglied der Europäischen Union werden
ja oder nein ich glaube das ist
geographischen Song Contest sind sie
schon mal
ich kenne das Land ein bisschen wie
sagen also da teilen wir viele
gemeinsame Werte nicht alle
möglicherweise aber sehr sehr viele und
ich bin der Meinung dass wir eben nicht
nur eine Wertegemeinschaft sind dass die
Grundlage von allem ist und diese Werte
kann sie in Europa nicht funktionieren
der Europe of Life ist das was uns
ausmacht das Europäer sondern das ist
auch eine Identität der
Zusammengehörigkeit gibt auch in Fragen
der Geographie weil wir hatten einen
Antrag von Marokko Mitglied der
Europäischen Union zu werden der wurde
gar nicht behandelt weil jeder sagt das
ist so klar Afrika so klar nicht Europa
das war einfach über das gar nicht
verhandeln brauchen aber wirklich
die europäische Idee und das ist ja
wirklich wertvoll ich glaube wir haben
die beste Leben in der besten aller
Welten wir haben Freiheit und
und ich glaube man kann sich keinen
besseren Lebensstandard und das Sagen
übrigens auch alle bei meinen Kinder USA
unterwegs ist was das beste Land das ist
Europa und diese europäische Idee
weiterzutragen auszuweiten das sollte
nicht an den jetzigen Grenzen enden und
natürlich muss man selber voll
Mitgliedschaften sprechen aber warum
könnte es sein nicht irgendwann mal Teil
einer europäischen Verbindung ja ich
meine sie
definiert
dahin
öffnen desto mehr werden
diese Kandidaten Beitrittskandidaten
assoziationskandidaten für uns gewinnen
aber entschuldigung
ich glaube das ist eine inzwischen doch
eurozentristische Sichtweise die nicht
eurozentristisch eurozentristische
Sichtweise die nicht mehr der heutigen
Realitäten entspricht ich glaube der Zug
ist längst abgefahren im Fall von der
Türkei die Frage ob die Türken jetzt nur
darauf warten dass die EU sie wieder mit
offenen Armen ganz andere Frage die Frau
drüben beantworten kann ob die das
wollen aber sie also sicherlich gibt es
solche Leute noch und es gibt sicherlich
auch noch Länder die in die eu-streben
aber ich glaube wir befinden uns
inzwischen in der Weltordnung die
Richtung Multipolarität geht und wo
plötzlich ganz andere Kräfte eine Rolle
spielen die durchaus attraktiv sind dann
auch für Länder wie die Türkei und da
reden wir von Zentralasien china macht
wird massiv um diese Länder und hat auch
viel zu bieten also ich glaube
wir müssen uns davon verabschieden dass
alle nur auf darauf hoffen irgendwie in
die EU zu kommen wir erleben ich glaube
diese Wahl ist noch mal einfach noch mal
ein Beleg wie sehr sich die Welt
insgesamt auch verändert nämlich dass
wir uns
es ist im Grunde eine der der
westlichen Demokratie der liberalen
Demokratie weil sich plötzlich in
anderen Zusammenhängen ganz neue
Formation entwickelt
also wir haben wir wir denken ja auch
immer noch im Fall der Ukraine die ganze
Welt ist gegen Russland in keine kriegt
das ist ja überhaupt nicht der Fall wenn
wir genau nach äh Zentralasien in den
mit Nahen Osten gucken teilweise
bisschen nach Südafrika oder Brasilien
Brasilien anschauen alle momentan eine
Chance ein bisschen auch diesen
Eurozentrismus eins zu wissen oder auch
den besten und sich neue Formation und
neue Möglichkeiten anzuschauen und das
auch gegenseitig okay zu spielen also
deswegen ich glaube wir müssen die
Fragen inzwischen ganz anders stellen
als die Frage noch sollen wir die Türken
mit offenen Armen empfangen oder nicht
die Frage ist Frau drüben wollen die das
überhaupt das wird mich mal
interessieren weil es ja genau die
Argumentation von Herrn Lee da sagt pass
auf die also wo stehen die denn in
Zukunft man sieht es ja an jemandem wie
Erdogan der ist irgendwie an der Seite
von Putin liefert aber gleichzeitig
Waffen in die Ukraine macht Geschäfte
mit den Chinesen hat aber gleichzeitig
ich sag mal uigurinnen sind da gibt's
eine enge Beziehung zur Türkei also man
könnte immer sagen pass auf das sind
deine Brüdern und Schwestern kümmer dich
bitte mal um die das hat er glaube ich
ein einziges Mal gesagt dass das eine
schwere Menschenrechtsverletzung ist und
dass das nicht geht was dann in China
mit den Uiguren passiert aber ab da
haben wir das Wort nie wieder gehört
was war das Wort Nummer genau
das nie wieder gehört und stattdessen
macht man Geschäfte und die Russen bauen
Atomkraftwerke bei ihm also das ist
genau das was er liebe schreibt im
Grunde nach allen Seiten sozusagen wir
sind Freunde also Erdogan verfolgt ja
diesen Ansatz also aus seiner Sicht
strategische Autonomie er kann mit den
Russen er kann mit den Chinesen er kann
mit den Europäern mit den Amerikanern
das ist so die Position die er hat seine
Anhänger finden das auch gut ich glaube
aber trotzdem dass die Frage des
EU-Beitritts eine Rolle spielt und da
müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt auf die
Regierung gucken sondern auf den Rest
des Landes und die Opposition also es
ist ihr ja gelungen mehr Stimmen auf
sich zu vereinen als vorher das heißt ja
erdanz Basis ist sehr stark und er hat
gewonnen aber wir haben ungefähr knapp
die Hälfte der Wählerinnen und Wähler
die den Wandel wollen und wenn wir jetzt
die Tür zuschlagen dann sagen die
Europäer eigentlich ja wir glauben nicht
mehr an die Demokratie in der Türkei und
ich glaube das wäre ein fatales Signal
an jene die diesen Wandel wollen die die
Demokratie wollen und zweiten Punkt noch
wenn wir den Beitrag beenden würden
jetzt das wäre natürlich gefundenes
Fressen für Erdogan also er könnte sagen
ja guck ich habe es euch immer gesagt
die Europäer die wollen uns nicht ne und
könnte man könnte sich so ein bisschen
dann als Opfer stilisieren und das ist
genau die Rhetorik die ihr lieber seine
Anhängern zieht und das würde glaube ich
im Endeffekt dazu führen dass ich die
Türkei weiter von Europa entfernt auch
wenn ein Beitritt zurzeit nicht
realistisch ist
alle die Erdogan gewählt haben keine
Demokraten sind dann nutzt es der
Erdogan genauso in der Türkei und sagt
ihnen haben wir jetzt gezeigt Respekt
zeigen Wähler Wille Respekt zeigen
gegenüber der Türkei ist fundamental
Interessen definieren gemeinsam und
daran arbeiten endlich Vorankommen wir
haben jetzt 20 Jahre
Beitrittsverhandlungen ohne dass in den
Kapiteln wirklich substanziell was
passiert ist wir könnten uns
zusammensetzen und über Energie Frage
reden wir könnten uns zusammensetzen
die Themen aber da passiert nichts weil
darüber schwebt diese Frage voll
Mitgliedschaft die von beiden Seiten
toxisches so ist es ist Realität dass
ich in den Gesprächen erlebe am Ende
Glauben wenige europäische Führer an am
Ende der Tage daran dass das
funktionieren kann deswegen lass es uns
zumindest mal für zehn Jahre mal zur
Seite legen vielleicht
also es würde ja de facto gar nichts
ändern
leere Forderung jedes Gespräch wird
sofort identifiziert mit der Frage bist
Mitgliedschaft so bin wie auch unsere
Runde beginnt sofort digital
zumindest vorschlagen lasst es uns für
15 20 Jahre mal weglegen wirklich nicht
mehr darüber reden sondern ganz
praktisch an ein Thema arbeiten und
eines zu eurozentriertheit ich bin ja
bei Ihnen und das Foto dass sie das Bild
ist sie eingeblendet haben mit Putin sie
und Erdogan
welcher Weltordnung werden wir morgen
liegen und da bin ich ehrlich gesagt
auch als Europäer 42% der Exporte der
Türkei gehen in die Europäische Union
der Türkei geht in die Europäische Union
was sage ich auch dem Erdogan in der
Zukunft ich will freundschaftlich und
partnerschaftlich arbeiten aber du wirst
dich auch entscheiden müssen du wirst
dich auch entscheiden müssen die Türkei
ist Mitglied der NATO und ich erwarte
auch von einem NATO wir haben Schweden
beispielsweise jetzt
vorliegen Finnland ist Mitglied anata
geworden danke auf der türkischen
Zustimmung und Schweden steht jetzt noch
an ich erwarte dass diese türkische neue
gewählte Staatsführung jetzt das grüne
Licht für Schweden gibt ansonsten werden
sich Grundsatz Fragen stellen auch in
wirtschaftlichen Kooperation
sind nach wie vor extrem wichtig für die
Türkei und manchmal sollte man das auch
zeigen ohne dass ich jetzt drohen will
aber ich will schon deutlich machen wir
sind verdammt stark als Europäische
Union wir sind der verdammt starker
Partner und deswegen wenn Journalisten
eingesperrt werden in der Türkei wenn
dort ein Prinzipien der des normalen
Wahlkampfs nicht respektiert werden dann
muss man auch bei diesen Themen Klartext
reden mit unserem Partner muss auch
sagen wir erwarten von euch ein gewisses
Verhalten weil ansonsten werden die
Beziehungen auch in anderen Bereichen
belastet werden was ich mir wünsche ist
dass wir unsere macht die Wahrheit haben
auch durchaus einsetzen und nicht immer
nur ein Anfang steht Internet
mit dem Kopf geschüttelt und dann Sie
Herr Li und dann hier dies ich meine
dass der Abbruch des Beitritt ist aber
nicht in diese Richtung gehen würde also
ich bin ja bei Ihnen wenn Sie sagen das
muss ja Konsequenzen haben wenn die
Türkei gegen westliche gegen europäische
gegen NATO Interessen handelt wenn dort
Menschenrechte nicht geachtet werden
wenn Journalisten im Gefängnissen sitzen
wenn gegen eine Oppositionspartei
vorgegangen wird ohne richtigen Grund
aus politischen Gründen klar auf jeden
Fall ich meine nur dass das natürlich
eine plakative Forderung ist den
Beitritt abzubrechen aber er würde
glaube ich konkret nichts bringen also
das hätte keinen Effekt weil es würde ja
de facto nichts ändern was wäre denn
anders
wir reden ja sowieso nicht über den
Beitritt sie wollten gerade ja das
Problem mit diesen 42 Prozent den Handel
zwischen Türkei und der EU sie haben
einerseits recht nur leider beruht
Handel auch immer auf Gegenseitigkeit
also wenn die eine Seite davon
profitiert profitiert die einen rauchen
wenn die andere da verliert verliert sie
andere Seite auch und meine Befürchtung
ist eher anders als noch vor 10 15 20
Jahren hat die Türkei das erleben wir
gerade auch in Russland Alternativen
also wenn die EU jetzt quasi der Türkei
die Tür zu schließt und da oder sagt wie
sieht das sagen okay ihr müsst euch mal
entscheiden und so weiter dann sagen so
okay ja wir spielen nicht mehr nach
euren Spielregeln weil es gibt ja
Alternative ist inzwischen und das
erleben wir ja deswegen müssen wir auch
Sanktionspolitik insgesamt
jetzt unter einem ganz ganz anderen
warum die Sanktionen nicht funktionieren
weil es inzwischen nicht nur China jede
Menge Drittstaaten gibt die plötzlich da
aushelfen und das da merke ich also wie
daher mein Vorwurf dieser
eurozentralität es funktioniert leider
nicht mehr wir sind nicht mehr
diejenigen die quasi die Weltwirtschaft
bestimmen sondern es gibt ganz viele
andere Akteure und das wissen genau
solche Leute und das macht es deswegen
fremde ich so ein bisschen mit ähm mit
so einer Rhetorik ähm
ich gebe Ihnen im Prinzip gebe ich ihn
ja völlig recht ich würde ja auch sagen
man muss man kann so jemanden doch jetzt
nicht noch belohnen aber ich glaube wir
müssen da jetzt plötzlich ganz andere
Faktoren mit einbeziehen warum das jetzt
alles viel viel schwieriger ist und wir
nicht nur sagen können irgendwie ey
Erdogan entscheide dich sie sagten
gerade Sanktion dies gilt glaube ich in
die Richtung und sagt wir müssen sowieso
überlegen diese dieser ewige Wettlauf
sozusagen um Sanktionen das ist eine
Sackgasse das war
absoluteskalation führt zu einer
Reaktionen beginnen irgendwo der der
Gegner setzt drauf und die großen
Verlierer in solchen sanktionsring
können schon auch natürlich wie es sein
wir sind exportorientierte Wirtschaft
wir leben davon dass wir freien Zugang
haben zu Rohstoffen zur Energie und das
einzige Märkten also wir sind davon viel
stärker betroffen als jetzt relativ
autonomischaden wie die USA oder wie
vielleicht sogar auch Russland oder oder
Kinder natürlich deswegen sollten wir
sehr vorsichtig sein mit
Sanktionspolitik und und häufig wird es
ja so politisch und jetzt verbieten wir
das und häufig ist auch nicht durchdacht
auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen das
was jetzt USA zur Eindämmung Chinas
macht und so das ist zum Teil sehr
zielgerichtet und so hat natürlich auch
wahrscheinlich weltpolitische Dimension
aber wir sollten glaube ich sehr
vorsichtig sein weil bei uns häufig doch
auch überschätzen in unserer
Einzigartigkeit wie wichtig wir sind für
den sie haben sie in Europa wächst nicht
mehr wir steigen hier als als Wirtschaft
Asien wächst über proportional und die
Türkei hat sicherlich mittlerweile
Alternativen ich würde aber ganz gerne
noch mal noch mal auch weil ich kann
viel von dem was der Weber sagt mitgehen
aber sie haben Anatolien gesagt ich sage
bewusst die westtürkheim hat mehr als
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung das ist
einfach Europa ja und das sollten wir
dem sollten wir uns öffnen und ob wir
setzen schneller Beitritt ist oder nicht
aber wir sollten zum betrachten
wir jetzt gerade hier diskutieren diese
grundsätzliche Frage wie umgehen mit der
Türkei haben sie doch am eigenen Leib zu
spüren bekommen als VW-Chef sie wollten
ein Werke in der Türkei aufmachen und
dann ist was passiert ja es gab dann
natürlich politische Interventionen zu
dem Zeitpunkt auch da gibt's natürlich
auch jetzt in Deutschland verschiedene
öffentlichkeitsgruppen die dann
Regierung sind gegen Regierung sind
alles ist das Projekt dann gescheitert
ich fand schade weil natürlich gerade
die Türkei in Landau machen
wo der Standort war noch nicht klar und
was dort zu tun
ist
welche Autos wie groß welche
Größenordnung ja schon überwiegend auch
für den Markt in der Türkei aber für
Europa die Türkei hat eine große
Bevölkerung die auch wächst die junge
ungefähr Bedarf an Autos ist auch ein
guter Produktionsstandort es gibt dort
Wettbewerbe es gibt asiatische
Unternehmen also die Türkei bietet sich
schon an hat sich auch qualifiziert als
Automobilstandort ne und sie hätten
gerne gemacht ja wir hatten wir hatten
sehr wohlgen und wir hätten gerne
gemacht und trotzdem Beteiligung der
Türkei am Syrien Krieg dann haben wir es
abgebrochen haben sie es abgebrochen
oder wurden sie aber wir haben
geschlossen
Sie persönlich wollten es weitermachen
im Unternehmen gibt es nur Gremien
Beschlüsse ja und im Gremium haben wir
beschlossen
sie wollten weitermachen weil sie die
Welt so sehen wie Sie es gerade
beschrieben haben in der Betriebsrat
wollte er nicht in der damaligen
Situation war es wahrscheinlich einfach
der falsche Zeitpunkt und aber ich würde
grundsätzlich immer wieder sagen ja
Investitionen in die Türkei und noch mal
sie hätten weiter gemacht oder stelle
ich jetzt einfach weil ich sie kenne ein
bisschen und weil ich ja weiß wie sie
die Welt sehen sie sagen das ist eine
riesige Chance sie haben sie auch gerade
sehr gut beschreiben
Betriebsrat sagt nein
automobilwerksinvestitionen sind
Investitionen für 40 50 Jahre alt die
gehen auch weit über den Präsidenten
Präsidenten hinaus aber man kann das
damals zurückstellen und dann fasst man
es wieder aber prinzipiell hatten sie es
für ein Fehler das nicht gemacht so nee
halt dich nicht wieder
gewesen wäre also weil die
Öffentlichkeit dann sehr negativ gewesen
wäre oder aus anderen Gründen nee aber
es ist einfach eine spannungssituation
gibt man ist ja als Automobilhersteller
auch immer wieder politisch man braucht
Subventionen von der einen Seite man
braucht die Unterstützung von der
anderen Seite ist immer auch ein
politisches Unternehmen und wenn die
politischen Rahmenbedingungen nicht
passen dann kann es nicht tun